Еммануель Макрон любить помпезні виступи
Однак на цей раз у своєму телезверненні він виправдовувався
за свою позицію протягом останніх днів
Я визнаю свою частину відповідальності
Можливо, я мимоволі справив враження, що те, що відбувається, мені байдуже
що у мене інші пріоритети
Я також знаю, що багатьох зачепили мої заяви
Промова Макрона зібрала біля екранів мільйони французів
Багато хто, як у цьому альпійському селі на південному сході Франції
слухали його, зібравшись разом
Адже президент змусив чекати на своє звернення надто довго
(глядачі): Бууууу!
Він присвятив нам цілих тринадцять хвилин
о, як багато, з огляду на ту кількість днів
які ми протестуємо, починаючи з 17 листопада
Однак було кілька обнадійливих моментів
Збільшення мінімальної зарплати на 100 євро -
це добре
Зменшення соціальних зборів з пенсіонерів - це також крок вперед
І ще він дав зрозуміти, що концерни-гіганти Гугл, Еппл, Фейсбук і Амазон
повинні будуть, нарешті, сплачувати податки
Добра промова. Але я йому абсолютно не вірю
Нам потрібні докази
Думаю, він злякався. Він відчуває, що стало спекотно
Він розтратив кредит довіри
і повинен піти у відставку
Молодий президент, що мав намір реалізувати цілу низку  масштабних перетворень
опинився перед складним вибором
Щотижня тисячі французів
переважно низького достатку і жителі передмість, беруть участь в акціях "жовтих жилетів"
Спочатку протести були викликані підвищенням цін на автомобільне пальне
Однак до них додалася вимога про зменшення податкового тягаря в цілому
і підвищення мінімальної оплати праці
Ми протестуємо, тому що у нас дедалі менше грошей в гаманці
Податок на пальне - добрий приклад
Він і так вже дуже високий,
а його все підвищують і підвищують
Податок на пальне мав стимулювати французів
користуватися громадським транспортом і купувати електромобілі
Але тепер важлива економічна реформа,
по суті, заморожена
Влада вже відтермінувала
введення податку на півроку
А тепер погодилась і на інші поступки
Ми хочемо зробити Францію такою, щоб у ній можна було жити на задовільному рівні
Але робота в цьому напрямку рухалася надто повільно
Я маю намір швидко і конкретно розібратися з цим
Незважаючи на фінансові "подарунки" Макрона
"жовті жилети" запланували
нову акцію наступної суботи
Може скластися враження,
що Париж ось уже кілька днів
у владі вандалів і мародерів
Саме вони насамперед створюють телевізійну картинку
хоч їхня кількість порівняно із загальною масою протестувальників відносно невелика
Поліція затримала востаннє понад тисячу тих,
хто чинив насильство
Переважна ж більшість "жовтих жилетів" протестують мирно
Згідно з опитуваннями французьких ЗМІ
72 відсотки французів
підтримують вимоги "жовтих жилетів"
але при цьому 85 відсотків чітко висловилися
проти застосування насилля.